everyone this is kevin from the chess
website comm and today we're gonna be
continuing our series in mating patterns
and this is our second part in the
series and the first mating pattern that
we are going to go over today is damiano
is mate and as you can tell it arises
from the situation right here where you
have either a pawn or a bishop on g6 it
really doesn't matter each one and we
have our Queen here on the open H file
and as you can see here we don't have a
pawn here on it our H file doesn't
really matter as long as the H file is
open or semi open that we can have
access to the King here and it's White's
move and Y can bring his Queen to h7 and
checkmate the King the king has blocked
off from f8 there is a piece on f8 and
he can't come to this f7 square because
our pawn or Bishop is in the way so this
is damiano mate now let's take a look at
example and see how we can apply that to
an actual game and here's our example
and it's White's move and as you can see
I've replaced the pawn with a bishop
here just to show you it really doesn't
matter which one we use and I didn't
want to go over just the concept take a
minute if you want to do it on your own
and think about White's best move in
this case and remember think about
damiana those make that we're trying to
look for and remember no matter what you
can do sacrifice whatever pieces you
have to to make sure you can get that
particular situation in a game because
it's checkmate and that's what we're
going for so take a minute
hopefully you came up with the move rook
to h8 and it's a sacrifice move blacks
only move is to capture this rook you
can't come to s7 or h7 because of the
bishop and you can't come to 87 because
of our rook as well he has to take on h8
we can now bring our rook to h1 check
again he has to move back
we can now sacrifice another rook on h8
again he has to take on h8 we can now
bring our queen to h1 he is forced to
retreat once again to GA and here we
have Damiano knows mate we can bring our
queen to h7 and checkmate
so as you can see in this situation we
actually sacrifice two rooks but in the
very end
since we know what da Minos made it is
we had a pretty easy win mate in five so
let's go ahead and take a look at the
next example mating pattern
the next meeting pattern is more fees
made named after one of the greatest
chess minds of all time and it looks
like this as you can see we have a
bishop on f6 attacking the King and the
G file is open for our rook so the King
is recommended he can't go anywhere so
we are using our bishop and our rook in
this situation obviously a queen would
work here but for simplistic reasons
bishop and rook is all you need in this
case let's go ahead and take a look at
an example how we can use this in a
normal game in this example if you look
at it most people would actually think
that black has a better position his
King looks very well protected and if
you can see he's up in material but
since we know more fees may we can use
the rules that we've looked at to
approach a game where we know the ending
is going to be good for us so take a
minute and think about where you think
white should go so that we can approach
more if he's mate and hopefully you came
up with the move Queen captures f6 now
from here we are threatening Queen takes
on g7 checkmate so they're going to have
to defend that once they take on f6 now
where do we go we bring our rook to g1
check and when the King moves we can now
come in with our bishop capture on f6
and checkmate so from here it looked
like a pretty even
situation that even look like blank was
ahead but we were able to have a queen
sacrifice because we knew more fees mate
and we have a pretty easy win so let's
go ahead and take a look at the next
example this is kind of like more fees
mate and it's more fees concealed mate
more fees concealment is very similar to
more fees mate but there's one
additional step that you have to take
and we're gonna go to that now so pause
the video and see if you can try to
figure out how to mate in this case as
white the first move is going to
hopefully you figured out the first move
is rook captures on g7 the black king is
forced to move to h8 and now the key
move right here a lot of players will
want to move their rook back to g1 this
is actually going to be a huge mistake
black can move his pawn to f6 blocking
our Bishop and blacks actually has a
better game here he has more material
and we no longer have the morphe mate
threat that we had before so instead we
need to play a different move instead of
rook to g1 and instead of rook g1 we
know that when we move our rook it's
going to be a discovered attack from our
bishop on b2 so we want to remove this
defender on f7 and capture him on f7
we're checking with our bishop but now
that pawn is not going to bring him as
anymore trouble
so now when the King moves back to g8 we
can now check on g7 the king is forced
to move to h8 we can now come back to g1
now when the King moves excuse me now
the rook is gonna have to come to f6 to
block and now we can capture on f6 with
our bishop and it's checkmate so there's
a one extra move with Morpheus
concealment that you have to know to
make sure that you don't make a huge
blunder and bring the rook back to g1
and instead you take the defender from
f7 so
those are both more fees mate and more
peace concealed mate let's go and take a
look at the next mating pattern the next
banding pattern is called Reddy's mate
and it looks like this your Bishop is on
d8 the king cannot move to b6 and you
can't move to the D foul because of our
rook and our Bishop is protected by our
rook on d1 and it comes about we heard
about this from one of the most famous
games that a lot of you have probably
already seen and it comes about from the
situation like this so take a minute if
you haven't already seen this puzzle it
would definitely be good puzzle to try
on your own but see if you can reach
this position on your own and hopefully
you came up with a brilliant sacrifice
and that is Queen to d8 and as you can
see here the King has to capture can't
move to e7 or d7 he has to capture the
Queen from here black hat excuse me
White has a fantastic move of Bishop to
g5 double check and any time a king is
in double check he has to move his king
he cannot move any other piece so the
black king is forced to move
if he moves to be eight we can bring our
rook to d8 and it'll be checkmate it
doesn't matter in this case we'll go
ahead and put the black King on c7 just
we can have the same setup as Reddy's
mate that's what happened in the real
game and we can bring our Bishop to d8
and it's checkmate but again even if the
black king moves to eight we can bring
our rook to d8 and it's checkmate either
way but as long as you know the
situation and how it'll arise and it
normally happens when the king is not
castled for black or white depending on
which way it's set up and why this
castled on the Queen side so his rook is
lined up on the D file so that is
Reddy's mate and the next one we're
gonna look at is smothered mate it's one
that you'll see very very often it's the
last mate that we're gonna look at so
we'll go ahead and take a look at
smothered mate splendor mate looks like
this the king is trapped in and is
checked by the night here on f7 and
can't move he's what they called
smothered and this is going to be the
most common besides the back rank made
that you're gonna find and a lot of
players there's so many opportunities
for smothered mates because they just
don't know what to look for and so we're
gonna take a look at an example there's
a lot of different examples out there
but we're gonna go ahead and take a one
look at it and see something that you
should be looking for when it comes to
smothered mate so the example we're
gonna look lat as here and as you can
see white is down a whole lot of
material but we have a knight near the
black King and the black King is near
the corner and we have a very active
piece our white Queen on the e-file
they can jump into the action very
quickly when you see this you should be
looking for smother in May so take a
minute see if you can figure this out on
your own and hopefully you came up with
the move Queen to e6 check now black has
two options here is first move is to
move into checkmate immediately with
King to f8 and then we can check mate
with f7 that's usually not gonna happen
instead you'll normally see the black
King come to h8 now here's where it gets
interesting we can bring our knight to
f7 check the only move black has is to
move back to g8 and here's the tricky
move right here it's night to h6 to
discover check with our queen and we're
putting our Knight where we want him to
go so like we said before the King has
to move he's not gonna move to f8
because he'd be moving into checkmate so
he's gonna move back to h8 and then here
we can bring our Queen to g8 check the
black King cannot capture because of our
Knight
the only movie has is to capture with
his rook on g8 and from here the final
blow Knight to f7 checkmate so you will
see smothered mate and various traps in
the beginning you will see some other
mates at the end of games but always be
looking for especially when a knight is
around a king you don't necessarily need
a queen involved but many times you can
have a nice little Queen sacrifice with
a knife